allez
à la fin de chaque année à la réunion au
delà des traditionnels voeux et des
cadeaux s'il ya bien un souhait que
pratiquement chaque habitant de l'île
fait c'est de pouvoir au moins une fois
à cette période
manger un délicieux carrie bichiques le
bichiques désigne l'alevin de deux
espèces de poissons très proches mais
distinctes le cabot à tête de lièvre et
le cabot bouche ronde tous deux de la
famille des globules dès que l'on trouve
dans les eaux tropicales côtière des
îles de l'océan indien à l'embouchure
des rivières ainsi qu en eau douce après
avoir pondu en amont des rivières le
poisson boisset eux emportés par le
courant jusqu'à l'océan
les alevins les bichiques donc ne se met
à remonter les cours d'eau caen était à
la réunion
cette nouvelle se répand rapidement de
bouche à oreille sous la forme de
bichiques la montée mais voilà depuis
quelques années dans certaines rivières
de l'est de l'île l'alevin se fait rare
nous sommes à l'embouchure de la rivière
des roches ils ont et baby sont deux
pêcheurs de bichiques ils entretiennent
leurs canaux toute l'année sur la rive
côté bras panon une ligne de cabanes et
les pêcheurs y ranger leur matériel qui
a évolué avec le temps
anciennement 980 y pêcher avec sa moue
fia comme ça ça c'est le matériel
d'aujourd'hui avec une jante de vélo un
petit bout de métallique un morceau
l'ombrière ça peut être fait en une
demi-heure à peine quand les bichiques
remonte les cours d'eau ils sont avides
m'empêcher grâce à une série de nas
conique appelez-vous elles sont placées
à l'embouchure des rivières
ils vont pêche depuis son enfance pour
lui une chose est sûre il y a beaucoup
moins de bichiques qu'avant mon péché
dans un canal près du radier bien les
bichiques qui était en dessous il était
mort asphyxié par la quantité manquer
d'eau ou à la 30e musique
tout le monde y arriver il pouvait faire
son petit canal et voilà qu'en serbie
chez colruyt par rapport à la quantité
de les laver
mais maintenant c'est plus le cas là
depuis deux ans n'y a rien
denis naissent dit baby est lui aussi un
pêcheurs de bichiques il se rend tous
les jours près de son canal dans son
enfance quand d'autres jouets lui pêcher
les bichiques pour payer son goûter et
des sa mère a fini longtemps et elle est
gravée longtemps ils savent à des
magasins et acheter des pièces des
écoles du prochain passage en musique
est vrai est vrai était sûre aujourd'hui
un temps qui est aujourd'hui révolu car
le bichiques se fait rare la pollution
le réchauffement climatique la
modification de la largeur des cours
d'eau bref tant de paramètres qui font
dire aux pêcheurs que les temps ont bien
changé c'est le même constat dans tous
les métiers longtemps et celui de
pêcheurs de bichiques ne déroge pas à la
règle
la rivière est elle aussi désertés par
les jeunes aujourd'hui et
la zone des sables la rivière les sables
est partout et là les jeunes feuilles
comment est la vie réussie donc gagné
génération mes pensées et son d'attentes
temps de travail pour peu de résultats
on le sait bien ce qui est rare est cher
c'est le prix que chaque année les
amateurs friands du petit alvin sont
prêts à payer pour ce qu'ils
considéraient comme le caviar pays